it was important for a million reasons
but you know obviously the the fans of
star trek uh and i'm a late adopter i
mean to be totally uh honest i've said
this since the you know the 2009 movie i
was not a star trek fan as a kid and i
realized what i missed out of them
because i got to fall in love with it
watching the shows when i started
working on the film um and
justin lin who is an extraordinary guy
and a wonderful director and he did an
amazing job on this
he was a star trek fan
from i think the very very beginning i
mean he would watch his parents and
everything he loved and knew this world
so well
and he was really inspiring to talk to
and i just felt that this was someone
who unlike myself loved it from the
beginning uh and though i fell in love
with it later uh i feel like this is you
know we were so lucky all of us to get
to work uh with justin on this move well
i i don't see any reason to uh to to to
drag on any longer shall we bring justin
all right
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
we have we have actually pulled justin
out of the edit suite you're you're
trying to unlock it and blocking it
tonight
so we're reading what we're doing here
is wasting your time
from finishing the film it must be what
is it like to step out of the edit suite
the cave of the edit suite and out into
this the the fan event
if it's
surreal is definitely the right word
yeah
you you were raised on star trek bottle
fed on it and seeing all the movies all
the tv shows the animated series within
that whole canon was there always
something that star trek that you wanted
that you wanted to add
i think that's part of so attractive you
know i think it's it's a shared journey
with with these characters with this
great crew
but at the same time you're pushing into
unknown you know i think that's that's
what i love about is embracing stuff you
know with these characters that's been
you've been done for 50 years but at the
same time we're constantly pushing and
and challenging ourselves well there
must have been a time when you're
sitting on set thinking
holy crap i'm directing a star trek
and that that happened every minute i
mean
there's always that that that lag of
three seconds of me bouncing back to my
living room as a ten-year-old and back
to onset
how do you how do you try
what in what part of your head you park
the history of star trek and hold on to
it to push it forward or try to ignore
it
and i'm sure that's not connected
i think you have to embrace it you know
i think that's what makes it great and
um you know i think what jj's done so
great is that
we can celebrate embrace everything
that's that's in the last 50 years but
at the same time we have these big
characters are going into these new
adventures
and they're going to make choices and
they're going to face challenges and
they're going to keep evolving and
growing yeah i gotta say just one thing
that uh justin did you know a few months
back there was a fan movie
axanar that uh was getting made and
there was this lawsuit
that happened uh between the studio and
these fans and justin and i need to tell
the story because he uh was sort of
outraged by this as a long time fan and
uh we started talking about i realized
that this was not you know an
appropriate way to
deal with the fans the fans should be
celebrating this thing like you're
saying right now
we all
fans of star trek are part of this world
and so um you went to the studio and
pushed them to
stop this lawsuit and now uh within the
next few weeks it will be announced this
is going away and fans will be able to
work on
[Applause]
you're getting the gift of promoting
another young director who may end up
being part of the franchise yeah i think
jessica will resent it
um no i hear you have a special audience
audience surprise tonight
yeah
well since everybody's here and we're
celebrating everything that's come um we
have a limited edition poster um
all right i'd like to ask you guys a few
questions um
hold on a second i broke them down but
there they come up
over the last 50 years star trek has
evolved as a franchise through movies
through television um
wait i already asked that question
but it was ask it again
actually here you go um
having grown up on star trek was there a
moment of excitement that you remember
as a kid that you wanted to try and
replicate for an audience member now
from your film
well i mean i think you know getting
beamed up i think that was always the
thing when i was a little kid you know
and so i remember stepping into the
hallways within the prize and
if the lights were not they're still
like painting it and stuff and just
walking in there and feeling like wow
i'm now part of this and they're asking
like what color of white you want that
wall to be
um that those moments are
definitely you know something
blockbusters why by star trek you know
i was actually shooting in the
tournament i got the call from engaging
you know and it
it's something that's a very personal
choice you know i i just couldn't resist
uh hopefully contributing something and
sitting dinner after 50 years hopefully
they build something that can continue
it for another 50 years that's that's
going to be an intense call to get
it's been intense and relentless but i
think
and part of it is
i think everybody cares and then we have
a great group of people the cast is
amazing you know i got the all-star team
to come and um it's it's been a dream
come true and some great new additions
now in beyond the crew get separated
from the enterprise and from each other
what does this departure mean to the
crew and what do you think it means for
the evolution of starkville
it means anything can happen you know i
think that's what's so fun about being a
part of this is that you know
these characters and themes and we can
go anywhere
and we can evolve and then
they're going to run into new challenges
and and nothing should there should be
no boundaries and talk about intense to
the story that you and of course doug
young and simon peng wrote the script um
and the story that you pitched was
it felt so life and death and so
frightening uh and and very much like an
episode of the show but at large it was
an amazing pitch to hear like in the
very early days
okay so where and when um are people
first going to get to see
beyonce well we're partnering with uh
comic-con and we're gonna do our
premiere in san diego on july 20th
it's gonna be i believe the first time
ever imax outdoor no way
[Applause]
everyone who has come here tonight as
you leave will get credentials
[Applause]
there's no way to follow that so
coming up
[Applause]
feels
familiar correct was part of my life
since it was on every day the crew
became our family
it was very exciting to be a part of
this franchise i wanted to establish a
tongue that is unique
but at the same time feels familiar to
the star trek we all grew up on
making a star trek picture is like
making no other picture
just i'm charming about three two one
[Music]
because it's star trek we could do stuff
i've never been able to do on another
movie like a gold canyon a blue planet
that said we built into the wrong party
was a huge undertaking from start to
finish we rearranged the whole quarry
into our set
tom works in the most unique way of any
designer i work with in that he works
largely with physical models that are
unbelievable
i certainly know you're a statutory
picture at when's 50 aliens walking
around
the scope of this film is tremendous
since it was his 50th anniversary we
wanted 50 different unique alien races
there are more aliens in this movie than
another the other ones combined
it's monumental the amount of work that
this crew generator she's tying jayla's
with one hair at a time there was a very
conscious effort to make jayla iconic
the elegance of the lines is really what
makes her stand out i like that second
skin i like what he brought to me
the important thing to justin was that
the movie was diverse especially in a
movie like this where there are people
from all over the galaxy
i definitely have envy of chris
and anton's survival suit
justin also wanted to modify the
existing look of this happy birthday
folks our costumes have a little bit
more of a retro feel but yet modernized
and catered to this world and long
sleeves on the women's uniform and other
women on the set were all very pleased
that women finally get wrecked
what's been most special for me is
getting the gang back together
[Music]
i've just been really enjoying how weird
and funny everyone is the cast was so
welcoming we're all fans of each other
which is great it's been an absolute
delight this movie is fun it's intense
there's great heart it was pretty
amazing to be part of that for life
[Music]
[Applause]